did i do uh angry east coast comics no i
don't think so it's new york or boston i
like the premise of a guy who's his idea
is predicated on being angry and
disappointed who becomes incredibly
successful but still has to conjure up
anger
no it drives me [ __ ] nuts
[ __ ] meter maids you know driving a
[ __ ] goal caught a round payment
ticket drives me nuts how you doing i
got you know i got property you know i
got some condos in santa monica i got a
castle in switzerland what's your net
worth about 150 million but you know
what drives me out of my [ __ ] mind
convertibles put a [ __ ] wolf on the
bus
you're driving around with the [ __ ]
rope
you know what drives me nuts cyclone
fences what get a [ __ ] fence what do
you got holes in the thing so you're
saying you're worth about 150 million i
got about 150 million lodge i just
bought an apartment building on the west
side it's looking pretty good
would you say most of your dreams in
life have come true yeah you know i own
a lot of property i'm pretty much set
wow i got a g5 i fly in that i go
you're happily married and you've got
kids and everyone's healthy everything's
good so what's bugging you driving me
nuts you know what drives me out of my
[ __ ] mind ladies and gentlemen tables
you can't you can't hold the bedrooms
you gotta put a [ __ ] beverage on a
[ __ ] table hold your [ __ ] drink
drives me out of my mind
now i gotta go to
i gotta go get my suit fit and i'm
buying a ten thousand dollar soup but
you know what drives me out of that
[ __ ] skull that's that what's that
cotton candy
is it a food product is it app
i love that the more stuff that happens
great for this guy yeah i mean hey guess
what you just uh yeah through some weird
codicil in an old manuscript you now own
most of maui we just realized and so
it's been seeded to you it's now you you
now own all of maui and you get to own
it and you can sell it if you want
you're now the richest man in the world
i got an island but you know what drives
me on what's that out of my mind what's
up curly fries
[ __ ]
have a straight fly what am i gonna do
with a [ __ ] circle [ __ ]
what are you doing a curly fry give me a
regular [ __ ] fries drives me nuts i'm
buying a yacht
you know this is this is unprecedented
uh i just got word and no human uh and
has ever been told this in the history
of civilization
but i've just been told that uh there
has been direct communication with god
and you are going to heaven and you will
enjoy heaven uh and the entire afterlife
for all eternity all of your dreams and
wishes will come true and you'll see all
your loved one it's been verified you're
going to have it no matter what you do
you know what drives him out of my
[ __ ] mind
spatulas
you can scrape it with a spoon or a
regular knife a spatula
[Applause]
in a weird way
i'm swearing a lot no no don't worry
about it what is this for nick at night
take it easy that's very annoying
no but you know what it's it is funny
because the person that makes me think
about sometimes it's a it's almost
touching a little on seinfeld
unintentionally but in the way
everything has gone right for him in
every way possible
but he's still
very wealthy and beloved and everything
always goes this way but he still has to
go like you know i got a problem like
you really don't yeah
yeah no he's not mad but it's just he's
still got to come up
jerry is there anything wrong do you
have any problems no
is anything said yeah but he's uh he's
he and leno oh sorry that's okay well
come on what are they talking about it's
been 11 years people would have had ways
of encountering
they haven't told them yet um just
people with like wait you know jerry was
always kind of he's like maybe two years
older than me but he was very much kind
of in a
superior position put it that way like
yesterday father figure you know yeah
because jerry was such a scientist about
doing stand-up and you know well you
need more punchlines check your setup
you know i would advise you i don't know
what character this is i i blew my voice
out on the other guy you know what trust
me [ __ ] nutshell on a [ __ ] podcast
the guy set you up for a half hour your
vocal cords are shredded you got another
45 minutes whenever i think about jerry
it's just always goes back to who are
these people that's that i always go to
that for some reason i'm not saying
that's a good jerry seinfeld because it
isn't but i just was like who are all
these people you know who are making
these sneakers i went for the i don't
know if i did this on our deep dive but
i do like doing it because it's such
such a non-sequitur jerry seinfeld as a
serial killer uh-huh what are you doing
what are you doing i'm gonna take out
your pancreas and cut around here then
we're gonna go right in there you know
that other rhythm he does yeah yeah like
i think i'm the guy to be president i
think i can cut out this we'll take your
kidneys go like that
that's that that other rhythm because
it's like who all of these people is up
here and then it's the guy who goes down
here i think i can do that
that's the one
layer that i think jimmy fallon should
do because he does an incredible he does
a great one